Oh my god.
Hello, everybody.
Happy Lunar Year!
Woo!
Three streams, and she still hasn't gamed yet for winning
Gamer of the Year.
She still hasn't done any gaming.
We are on day three of...
Okay, not day three.
This is like day four, day five.
Day five?
I fucking lost count, but three streams, still no gaming.
Still no gaming.
Don't worry.
That's going to be next week.
That will be next week, guys.
I have my schedule all fully planned out.
We will be gaming for real next week.
But yes, happy Lunar New Year.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
But yeah, oh my gosh.
I swear to God.
Okay.
I feel like I've been like speed running vtuber prep in six
days like this all of this would be like you know three to
four months of prep time and I'm trying to get everything
done in under a week like I'm already uploading shorts I
have a tick tock account now um I got my old thumbnail maker
I'm, it's, I've, oh my God, like every day is just like, all
right, gotta do, here's the list of things I can do this
time.
Here's a list of things I can do on the other day.
And then today I like, I like woke up, I like woke up at
like, uh, six in the morning.
I was like, all right, I can do this.
I can stay up all the way till my stream time.
And then I was doing work.
I was doing work all the way till like 12 p.m.
And then, and then I was like, I'm eepy.
I was just like, oh no.
How am I tired already?
Oh, oh no.
This is not good.
So then, so now I was like, okay, okay, I will take, I will
take a one hour.
Sorry, like my, okay, I have my giant ass fucking tablet in
front of me.
of me so like tracking wise is not not so great right now uh
my mouth be a little bit laggy today okay so like i was like
okay i'll take in one hour nap well guess who woke up at 4
30 also yes i almost said the wrong name on memberships i
was like hesitating because like it's It's so ingrained,
because I've been saying this other word for three years,
almost three years.
I was like, wait, no, that's not what it's called now.
That is not what it's called now.
But yes, memberships are open now.
Welcome to the tomato farm.
Yeah!
I've only, I grabbed that sub-bash of tomatoes from an
artist.
I retweeted the artist.
I don't have it pulled up at the moment, but shout out to
that artist for the...
tomato badge i have no idea all of these are like
placeholders right now because like i'm gonna be having a
new mama not very soon so so like i don't even know what
like my new skin suit's gonna look like you know when i shed
out this old skin suit and hop into the other one i have no
idea like there's no no no plan going on inside right now so
like all we know is that deep within all of us tomato and i
was like that's the safest thing because and that's why
there's all like placeholder emotes as well because i i
don't want to like commission all these emotes and then like
be like okay can you reach out later can you i'll just be
like okay um can you like um redraw all of these for my new
new skin suit and then so that would be very fucking awkward
So I was like, so like for now, we're just gonna have a
bunch of placeholder emotes.
I'll just be like, I don't know, I'll just MS Paint some
fucking placeholder emotes for all of us.
It might be just like all different pictures of like Doki
Amberdoge there, our resident dad.
So like, I'll just be like Photoshop pictures of dad.
Also, thank you all for the super chats.
Thank you for all the Akas and Magentas.
Thank you and all the other colors.
blue i think is one of them um but thank you everybody i
really really do appreciate it thank you i hope you guys
have a good lunar new year guys um i feel bad because like i
was supposed to have a uh you know a traditional like you
know lunar new year like lunch uh with my parents but then i
passed out at 12 so they're like well i guess i will happen
another day i'm like oops i'm sorry i was so fucking i was
so tired i didn't even i just not like i didn't like i
didn't like um i like slept in i felt like i slept enough i
did not stay up at all i like went to bed at like fucking 10
p.m or some and it was just like i'm i'm just i just die
i'll just i'll just fucking sleep i guess and and i'm like
why am i so fucking tired i'm still oh my god i don't know i
guess it's like I'm not used to streaming anymore.
I'm not, I, I'm just like not used to streaming.
So like my energy, look, during that past month and a half
or like month, I would just like play video games and stuff
and I won't talk, I really talk to people.
Like I, like even when I played games with my friends, like
I didn't really talk a lot.
I would just be like, like, I guess we would have like sort
of a conversation.
But like I was mostly like Hibernation mode for most of it
So like I was not ready to like And like okay And also I was
like you know Super fucking low energy when I'm talking to
people Because I'll just be like super low energy when I'm
talking to people So I was just not ready I was not ready in
life to like Use all my energy here Um but yeah Anyway
Anyway, today is the day we will name all of you and you
will finally have a name and you will have a form.
So today is the day.
It will be the day you guys will finally not be nameless.
No more arguing about what kind of name.
Oh, I forgot to change the gifting fucking picture.
God damn.
Okay.
i knew i forgot to do something um and we will you will
finally have some fucking form to all of you but for now not
yet though not yet we'll we'll get to that later we'll get
to that later um we're not one name i am absolutely vetoing
is free birds because Fuck that song.
It's a good song.
I will admit, it's a good song.
But fuck that song for demonetizing.
I like how like before I was like, oh, I don't care if it
demonetized.
I's not even monetized.
And then I got monetized and I'm like, oh, that's awkward.
I was like, yeah, I don't have the word.
worry I won't even I'm not even monetized well jokes on you
dokey you got monetized right after oh my okay you know like
the sudden realization that I had um I had like a sudden
realization today because if you guys didn't know uh wonder
fest is uh one one fest is going on right now Some of you
guys are like, wait, what's Wonderfest?
And well, Wonderfest is basically like the, like the, you
know, all the Nendroids and the Good Smile Company shit like
that.
Um, it's like they're really, they're showing, showcasing
all the new like products that they're releasing.
And I, did you guys know that I did not know this, but
they're going to be releasing pretty fast there.
Nendroid.
And then I realized I was like, wait a minute, I can
actually show that on stream.
I was like, oh my god, whatever I talk about, I can actually
show it on stream.
I can show the picture on stream.
It blew my mind.
I was like, I don't have to link the image anymore or be
like all right just google it i can actually show it on
stream oh my god anyway oh my god i need to show you guys
this i knew i downloaded i was like where the fuck did i
download this picture of freddy fast there's net sorry i was
like where is it oh my god look at this look oh my god i
can't believe there's a pretty holy shit i can't believe
there's a pretty fast don't worry this is transformative
this is transformative work right now so like i can't put a
picture of freddy fast bear next to me i was like it just
makes me wonder like what are the interchanging
interchangeable like face plates too like wait does that
make a put like, you can put like a head of like a, you can
put like the head of a different nendroid on top of Freddy
Fazbear's head.
Like, you can put Freddy Fazbear's head on different
nendroids.
Oh my gosh, the possibilities are endless.
I was so surprised.
I did not realize, I can't believe Freddy Fazbear has a
fucking nendroid, but yet he is not on Fortnite.
I'm so mad.
We can do the We can do the bite of 87
Oh my god I can't believe it though Where the fuck is my
Freddy Fazbear on Fortnite Like they have an android but not
Like a fucking Freddy Fazbear On fucking Fortnite It just
pisses me off It pisses me off But yes thank you every one
again For the memberships I really do appreciate who are
wondering who are new here that don't know um usually what
uh entails in a membership uh basically membership streams
will include like uh you know like gaming with me uh so like
i would open like servers and stuff where you guys can like
play video games with me like for example i'm planning on
for next week we're going to be doing garfield card next
week uh so in the member stream and also like uh there'll be
like other types of gaming servers that i might host in the
future like maybe a custom PAL world server or like custom
Minecraft server usually a Minecraft server I hope when I do
get it established I want to make that a super long term
other servers are tend to be short term because like in the
past I've done like one month of rust like a like a rust
server for members like for one month and stuff like that so
it really and then other things will be like you know like
sometimes members get to get to decide like the schedule or
like they they get to vote on the schedule and stuff or what
to do later on.
Also, I would be including, you know, exclusive wallpapers
that would be released in members.
And, uh, and like, you know, like, we used to do this thing
called, okay, I used to call it like average movie
watchalongs.
But now, now that I'm in indie, I can finally call it shitty
movies watchalongs.
Now I can call them shit so they'll be like sorry bad movie
okay shitty slash bad movies watch alongs in in in members
so we can we can we usually we usually do that as well so so
we don't have to be like quote-unquote average now i can
actually be like no they're actually terrible movies
um so so we can do like terrible like bad movie watchalongs
and that's really it like uh members is just like um it's
just a lot of like i think like the more fun part is like
the bad movie watchalongs and also the like uh the the
gaming streams like if i do like streams where i play video
games with you guys it's usually reserved in members um
unless it's like something like a where there's like a lot
of people or something like that like uh like i think like
the one time i made it public gaming was um was apex or
something i think that was the one time i don't remember so
there's a lot of streams blur together um but yeah anyway oh
my gosh little life update i contacted um a twitch staff
today um and i was so i was very like oh it's so weird I was
very grateful because the Twitch staff still loves me.
And he was like, oh yeah, yeah, Doki, if you still wanna do
Twitch rivals or like anything like that, like we will still
support you and we will still invite you to Twitch rivals
and stuff.
And like, I think they thought that I signed like an
exclusive contract with YouTube because they were like, we
thought you moved to YouTube forever.
I was like, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
It's the same thing.
I, like, do YouTube and Twitch sometimes.
I'm just dokey now.
I'm just...
I was like, no, no, no, no.
I'm just dokey.
That's the only thing different.
I'm just dokey now.
So, yeah.
And then, like, the Twitch staff was like, yeah, yeah, we
have, like, this event actually coming up.
Obviously, I can't say what the fuck they've...
And they're like, yeah, we can, like, get you in on this
next Twitch arrivals.
I'm like, yay!
Yippee!
Thank you!
I'm like, thank you so much!
I can still be like, I don't even go here, and I'm
participating.
I can still say that!
Yay!
So that was really nice.
I was like, oh my god, thank fucking god.
I could still do...
I could still do Twitch arrivals.
Oh my god.
Like, every day is just another thing to do on my checklist
of, like, all the other of, like, of, like, just be like,
alright, so usually a VTuber would have, you know, would, it
would take a VTuber, like, maybe, like, six plus months to,
like, get this done in their career, and then I'm like,
alright, gotta finish this in one day, gotta get all these
editors down in one day.
make a server for them so they can work together on clipping
my stuff for my channel all right gotta contact like like
overlay people shit like that boom one day done all right
set up the store boom one day done contacting artists to
make future merch boom another day god holy fuck oh speaking
of speed running i have to I have to make a new god damn it
you think they'll let me change guys can you can you like
name change your speed run speedrun.com username I these are
still my records those are still my
I swear, I am, you know what, I'll check that out later.
I'm going to see if I can name change my speedrun.com,
speedrun.com username.
For those who don't know, in the past, in the past, I've
submitted speedruns on speedrun.com.
They're not necessarily speedruns, but like, they're so,
they're so ridiculous.
that uh that like they still accept my runs so it'll be like
something like you know um if there's like there's like 30
submitted runs and then like the 29th run would be like some
like one hour something something to complete and then the
30th run will be me and it'll be like five hours and then
the mods there would be like you know what it's still she
submitted it She's still the 30th person to submit it.
So, like, I guess we accept it.
I guess we accept.
Except for one.
There was only one time I got fucking rejected.
And it was for fucking Peppa Pig.
Because the...
Out of all the games I've submitted, Peppa Pig was the only
time...
someone one of the mods rejected it because the mod was like
this is serious
like of course the pep the pig mods were the ones that told
me this is serious this is clearly not a speed run and I was
just like why why pep the pig of all the games why was it
Peppa Pig.
I was like, I would always like, I know.
I'm like, you know what?
Reasonable that, um, reasonable, uh, that, like, they would
reject me.
But the fact that the other moderators were like, he, he, ha
ha, let this anime girl, let this anime girl, like, make a
fool of herself.
But the Peppa Pig speedrunning community is very serious
indeed.
So don't submit, like, joke runs in the Peppa Pig.
a big community.
They do not take that kindly.
They are not here to fuck around.
It's a very serious speedrunning community.
I still couldn't believe that was that they rejected me
there.
But yep.
Yep.
Don't worry.
I Doki will continue on the tradition of submitting runs for
fucking stupid skitties.
like how someone chat was like peppa pig isn't just a game
dokey you don't understand there are like 0.001 like uh what
was this like it was like teleporting button teleporting
okay guys you can tell sorry I'm like a professional
speedrunner I do have like records on speedrun.com but like
uh I like invent my own terms okay that's what professionals
do we don't use the established terms that you normies out
there use we have our own specific personalized terms um
that only people within the speedrun community uses so
oh my god uh but that reminds me that i do have i should i
should i should make a new speedrun.com account okay guys
all right so um later on i'll be showing you guys uh The
Lunar New Year merch that'll be recently seen not today
because that'll be fucking crazy Me like I already have a
lot of things to do so it will not be released today even
though You know it would be the perfect time to release it
but like we me Mr. Man little man have a lot of work to do
with our current orders and our current and our um uh our
current like workload that we have to do so they'll be
released much later but like oh my gosh so there was this
one artist i uh contacted how much merch are we buying
double merch look guys rebuilding a shrine is a lot of work
also i don't mind if you guys like uh merge shrines and
stuff because you know it was so me and this current time is
still me inside so no matter what form i take we all know
within side me was still a tomato so like like you might not
have seen a tomato inside the other the other one but there
was a tomato inside inside of it so this is so in the end if
you want merge forms more shrines that's cool by me that's
cool by me like in the end there was always a tomato um but
yeah oh yeah speaking of i did not realize my tomato mama
was the person that made the shrimp miku because that shit
like i saw that what that comic went viral and i was like
what the wait who's this wait was this the person because
like i I remember I remember the day I asked them to make me
a to make my true for my tomato for him and it was like um
it was like on tumblr
that's why never I never realized what their twitter was I
like asked on tumblr so I was just like oh my god it's a
shrimp Miku so who those who don't know who the shrimp miku
artist was um the shrimp miku artist was the one that did
the shrimp miku i know it's it's so the the shrimp cooking
miku um that was you know like the hatsune miku contest that
they that they like host every winter so like um like their
design went viral and then like everybody really liked it
because the shrimp miku Miku was holding a knife.
Like, you know, they were like, no, Miku does not hold
knives.
I think that was like the funniest reasons why I never went
into the finals because they're like, no.
No knives for Miku.
It's like how they're like, Mickey Mouse must never hold a
knife.
Mickey Mouse must always be PG.
Mickey Mouse must never have a purse.
I know that you can be like the recent Mickey cartoon.
with the really funky art style that show was really good
that was a really good cartoon show but like if you guys
didn't know like the the handling of mickey mouse was oh my
god i can literally pick up put a picture of of mickey mouse
on my screen also the fact that it's public domain anyway so
like the the steamboat willy mickey but anyway but like like
the the thing about headlines about Mickey is that he must
not have a personality or like his personality must be
generic as fuck so that anyone can like so that so that like
he doesn't like he doesn't have any ideals that you can
imprint on him so he has to be like super generic with like
so that he does not
why Mickey cannot hold it.
Mickey cannot do any of those bad things.
Mickey is a self-insert.
I mean, even if it was a self-insert, if it was a
self-insert, at least he would have a personality.
But Mickey Mouse is meant to have no personality or like the
most generic fucking personality out there.
Um, because they don't want to like, because like he's now
just a mascot of like disney he's not like an actual like
he's not real i mean he i'm sorry he was never real but like
he he's just like the face of the company type deal like a
little puppet for everybody he's not like an actual like per
like a actual personality anymore um he's a jrpg protagonist
that Oh my god.
Oh yeah, a little fun fact.
Also another fucking fun fact.
You know like those that time when I like all I did to pass
the time was either play video games.
He's real to me.
What's it like to have the most fucking generic character as
your favorite Disney character?
I swear.
Even though like Mickey is like the face of Disney, he's
never the most he's never.
the favorite he's just like he's never the fucking favorite
if you ask people like who's your favorite Disney character
I more people would say Donald Duck then fucking Mickey
because like at least Donald has an actual personality and
shit like at least like people like fucking relates relates
to him because you're like wow my god he's like he's like
somebody that has a
Mickey Mouse.
Unless you want to buy, like, his Mickey ears that are,
like, $30 over price.
I can say all that.
I mean, I feel like I used to say this stuff, too.
But, like, I wouldn't be as harsh.
But now I'm like, now I'm like, well, I can sort of be
harsher now.
Unless Disney, if you want to sponsor me, I didn't mean all
that.
I swear.
I swear to God, I still love Disney.
I still love Disney.
Just not, not, Mickey's just not my thing.
I still, I still love Disney.
Just, just not Mickey.
Mickey is just not my favorite.
I think my favorite Disney character is, uh, uh, I think it
is, sorry.
I think it, isn't Donald, Donald was my favorite.
I'm not sure if current Disney is still Donald.
You know what?
Because I haven't, I think we all know, Disney movies, so
far, haven't been doing so hot.
Like, it hasn't been, like, doing that well lately,
including Pixar.
Because, like, the thing about Disney, I like how this is,
like, happy Lunar New Year.
But I'm just going off these, like, random fucking tangents
that are unrelated to Lunar New Year.
But, like, recently so far, recently so far, a lot of, like,
movies from Disney and Pixar are, like, all the franchises
that Disney owns, which is a lot of them, have been, like,
set to, like, they've, like, made so much money, and they're
so scared to fail now, that they go through the same fucking
formula over and over and over again.
making a new IP because they don't want to fail even more.
Because the last time they tried to make new IPs now, like
the last five years, is the fact that like, it didn't do so
well.
So now they're banking on nostalgia factor and making 5 to
10 plus sequels now.
Like, what did they say?
These are like this year.
They're going to be working on Toy Story, like a sequel for
Toy Story, for cars, for like, there's like so many fuck toy
story why the fuck does toy story need another sequel like
it ended perfectly also please tom hanks and the other guy
i'm sorry but like not gonna lie the other guy that plays
buzz light year he's really only he's really had his only
like work right now is toy story uh Tim Allen You guys can
be like I know you guys are like But Doki Tim Allen has done
this and this Yes in the 90s
I don't know if you guys No But like I feel like If you ask
like A zoomer Right now Who the fuck is Tim Allen They would
be like What What
it would be like who who is tim allen i don't think any
zoomer right now would know who tim allen is just know it
was the 2010s um yeah anyway uh michael theodore mouse is it
really i know like mickey mickey was like based off of
something walt disney wanted to like i don't remember i just
They're like, it was something related to Walt Disney.
Somebody related to Walt Disney.
But yeah, oh yeah, the Wish.
Yeah, that.
You know, like, the music?
Okay, I feel like everybody talked about the music of the
Wish.
But, like, the composers they got to write the Wish, like,
the music-wise, were, like, top 100, like, pop-song music.
And, like, that's fine and all.
music is not meant to be a pop song it's because like also
like pop songs are like usually about like you know like
romance and like love and like girl crushes or boy crush
mostly girl crushes they would be like oh my or like i mean
girls crushing on boys for like tweens and stuff and and
like and like so they weren't writing it as if the song has
a story that builds up to the Because, like, they're trying
to write a top-hit song per song.
So, like, none of the songs connected to each other.
Because normally, pop songs, you know, they don't connect.
Like, if you have an album full of pop songs from an artist,
they don't connect to one another.
They're like, there's no story behind it.
Each song itself, it's a story.
But not, like, not like a story from one story to another
story that leads up and connects to each other.
its own story that doesn't fucking make sense because it's
supposed to they want to have like a trendy song and then
here's another story that doesn't fucking make sense because
they wanted to try and get like a top 10 billboard pop song
and then um and then she becomes a fucking fairy god mother
i was like all right spoiler because i know for sure none of
you guys are gonna fucking My I just watched like someone
else so like this information you're getting from me is
basically I got it from another video so now I'm regurgit
you're basically getting a name researched that by going to
the theaters or so like this information is like fourth hand
you're getting fourth hand information so because I'm not
fucking watching paying money to watch wish uh but basically
and i don't think any of you guys are gonna watch wish in
the end unless like i don't know i don't know you're like a
disney completionist or something but basically wish ends it
because it's supposed to be a celebration of like a hundred
years of disney so like it's not meant to be it doesn't have
its own identity it's mostly it's like a nostalgia factor
based off of like its own IP.
So they tried to instill nostalgia.
Also, fuck the live action Pinocchio because they did that
too.
The one that I watched with my friend.
Like they had a scene where it's like, look at all these
Disney IPs that we own that we show with the clocks.
And I was like, why the fuck is this all Disney?
They're like, they're like, you want to see how much IPs we
own?
And it's like, cuckoo cuckoo And then you see like 10 like
hundreds of like Like miniature Disney IPs in like form of
Clocks and stuff So they keep doing that So So Um Anyway
Sorry I got a little pissed off because I can't believe I
watched Live Action Pinocchio For like it was I watched it
for 15 to 20 minutes And it was 15 to 20 minutes too fucking
long At the end of Wish, they were like, like the main
character becomes the fairy, the, what was it, Cinderella's
godmother or something?
They implied that she becomes the godmother, like the, the,
the godmother, the fairy godmother in Cinderella.
And I was like, what the fuck?
And then, and then they implied that all these people, like
the, the main antagonist, becomes the mirror in snow white
and I'm like why what the why like did they just retcon
their entire Disney lineup like I just it doesn't make sense
they retcon like the entire past of like Disney to be like
wish was the OG it was the original
So yeah, that's why I'm like, I'm not a huge, I don't know
if you guys noticed this, but I'm definitely, oh yeah, they
made, they made it a cinematic, as if we don't have enough
cinematic universes in the fucking world, they basically
made the Disney animation cinematic universe.
I was like, really?
So, anyway, I saved you guys, like, I don't know how long
wishes, but like, I saved you guys.
enough time to never watch wish because it is absolutely it
sounds terrible and like i don't want to put myself through
watching it because i feel like i already know it sounds
terrible and i listen to the songs and the lyrics make no
sense the dcau the dcau but like like okay Have you ever
listened I listened to one wish song and the lyrics don't
make fucking sense Like not even like grammar wise because
it's like they I don't remember the exact lyric But there
was like one part where they're like it's like they use our
a re instead of like I don't know is or something and it did
not make fucking sense at all I was like what what the fuck
is going on
um but yes okay we might watch wishes members maybe so we
can actually like figure out what the fuck is going on in
that movie like it's and then like pix i don't even remember
the last pixar movie like it's so soulless now that's what i
don't like a lot for those who don't know a lot of the pixar
staff and stuff got restructured and they left to Sony
animation, which is why Sony animation is very Sony
animation is like incredibly like, it's like doing very well
because Sony and DreamWorks, because a lot of old Pixar
okay, Elemental, not gonna lie, Elemental, despite how
fucked up the marketing was, it was actually a good movie.
like they for some fucking reason they fucked up the
marketing of elemental because for some reason they try to
like advertise the wrong thing for elemental so like a lot
of people were like criticizing it and stuff and then when i
finally watched it i watched it on a plane by the way most
movies now i just watched it on planes because like i can't
i i i don't have the patience to like sit sit down on my pc
because i don't go to the theaters to stream a movie because
i'm always like working and stuff but like it was i actually
cried in like some parts and but like they had like a a fake
movie for those who don't know elemental had a fake movie
reaction scene as a marketing thing because there was this
rock boy or this like was it this grass boy and like they
try to make him like the funniest character ever like he's
like try to make him a comic relief even though he was in
the film for like two minutes this little boy was in the
clawed yeah this little boy was in the film we're like two
to five minutes but they try to make him like the funniest
shit ever for marketing because like they the official
disney like tick-tock account or something the elemental
tick-tock account posted a fake movie reaction to when
claude came on screen screen sorry came on screen and there
it's like you know like Big Band Theory laughs and stuff.
They inserted like Big Band Theory laugh tracks and stuff.
Like, and be like, whoa!
And like, ah-ha-ha-ha!
Whatever Claude came on.
And like, oh my Claude!
And I'm like, what the...
And the movie...
And it was like, in a movie theater.
And then, like, quote-unquote, movie theater as, like, a
fake reaction marketing.
And, like, him so fucking hard and I was just like what the
fuck is he why but then like the movie itself wasn't bad it
was pretty decent it was really good but like they made
everybody be like whoa don't watch Elemental it sounds awful
because of the Claude marketing like yeah it's so it was
like the weirdest shit ever anyway um as much as like i shit
on new disney old disney was pretty great i still like
disney just not really new disney new disney is just too
fucking um formulaic now um i always felt it i knew it was
like getting super formulaic from i don't like marvel movies
this is my uh controversial take of controversial take
number 530 today uh I find I never really liked the Marvel
Universe because it was it was just this I like you know you
can be like no no but what about this movie it's just if you
look into the plot line like the story structure of the
Marvel Universe it's it's the same thing it's like it's it's
literally the into like 20 different movies it's so
predictable it's so it's so pretty I will admit like the
first you mean like the first two or three of the Marvel
movies other than Guardians of the Galaxy but that is
because James Gunn is a very talented director but then but
then James Gunn became formulaic too they like try to follow
the james gun formula because they're like because they're
like oh my god guardians of the galaxy did so well because
it never felt like a marvel movie it didn't feel like a
fucking marvel movie so then they were like oh my god we
gotta copy this now and every fucking movie started becoming
like guardians of the galaxy and it's like they add humor
when it wasn't supposed to be meant to be humor and it's
like that is my that is my rant of the day that is that is
that is that is um that is to my rant oh yeah also like
tight tight tight tidy or whatever his name he's also a good
director too he he's also like a uh a really decent Then,
like, then Disney tried to fucking...
It's like, I don't... They're like, you did so well.
Let's copy that.
And then it's like, no, the thing that they did so well was
what made it super unique.
If you keep fucking copying it, it's not gonna be unique
anymore.
Like, that's the thing.
If you keep copying it, it's not gonna be good because it's
the same thing.
Oh my god.
Anyway, I'm speaking my...
truth right now here i need i had like one month build up of
things i wanted to complain about and i'm getting out on
lunar new year by the way you're like but donky are we
supposed to have a name in the form guys let me speak my
truth then i'll name you guys then i will name all you guys
i need to speak my truth right now um if it sells it's sells
yeah but like it's so i i'm trying to remember there was
this director that was like i fucking hate superhero i
forgot which director said that but like there was a
director anyway if marvel wants to sponsor me i i love
marvel movies by the way just saying disregard everything i
said earlier i was it was just a joke i love marvel movies
anyway um um there was like this one director because like
he said like there's like no more soul it's all about making
money at that point um and that's why this director was like
i hate superhero movies because they don't care about
filmmaking anymore it's just all about movies that make
money so like and which i agree i agree every superhero
movie is all about like trying to trying to not be like good
story wise but like a good enough to make millions of
dollars like which is uh uh which i i hundred percent agree
i'm not even like a big movie person uh but like i i just i
just don't really enjoy joy superhero movies except if it's
dc animated because the funny thing about animated dc movies
is that they don't
like morally correct like they don't care about being
morally correct they actually go to places with their story
and for the DC animated movies they actually like care to
like do stuff with their stories and like surprise you with
like what they want to talk about um comics wise i will
admit like recent dc like even like comic wise recent dc
comics fucking not great uh the old ones were like the ones
in like 10 years ago were so much better versus recent uh uh
but yeah that's my truth of the day i sorry i went through a
long tangent regarding that you know what's cool though i
recently found out that santa claus is like an in in yeah
like in i was like in like marvel universe like in the did
you guys know that like i saw like a youtube short being
like santa claus is considered a mutant and and that's why
he can live for he can teleport to like houses all the time
and stuff like that yeah he's like i was like what the fuck
they made santa claus an x-men i was like oh my god what the
what the fuck um i mean that makes sense also speaking of
superheroes i heard like the suicide squad um very poor
timing with the name that i just said out loud okay i just
said it out loud i was like oh yeah that's what they're
called anyway i heard the new game for that was um was like
because they're built off of like the Arkham Asylum, the
Arkham Asylum games and like apparently I heard that like if
it wasn't in the same universe as Arkham Asylum it would
have been like an okay game.
The fact that it was like the fact that it was it built off
of like Batman Arkham Asylum and was also like Kevin Conroy
that's his name the voice actor of Batman.
that's been a voice actor of Batman for like um for like a
long long long time and that was like his last fucking role
and they did him incredibly dirty for his last role to be
fair they did the entire Justice League very dirty and like
like I read that like if it wasn't connected to Arkham
Asylum, it would, it would, it wouldn't have been like as
bad as, and so the fact that they fucked over Kevin Conroy
over there, it wouldn't have been as bad as of the
reception.
And I heard they might be deleting Steam Reviews, so I don't
know.
I don't know which is true.
I don't know who it is.
Oh, they lied about it being his last role.
that's fucked up that's actually fucked up they like they
knew they they knew exactly okay let's spoil it they kill
off batman in like the middle of the game they kill him off
and it was like the it was like done very terribly it was
done incredibly terribly how they kill him off it's it's
like it's really weird um so like uh so like so then they
were like this is going to be his last role and they knew
all right they if they knew how fucked up they're gonna kill
him off and then like why the fuck would they advertise it
as his last role knowing that like in high i guess like in
hindsight they didn't know how bad the reception was but
like i feel like if i was in the marketing room and i was
like we're gonna kill off kevin conroy i'm gonna tell
everybody that's his last role people are gonna fucking love
that like
Why the fuck?
Who thought people would love that?
Like, people are gonna fucking love that shit.
Like, um, but like, anyway, uh, what was I gonna say?
Oh, yeah.
Uh, that's why I was like, I heard they're deleting negative
Steam reviews, too.
But, like, I don't know if that's true.
I don't know if that's possible.
delete negative steam reviews i feel like knowing i feel
like overwatch 2 would have done that a lot really i was
like if that was possible i feel like a lot of games would
have done it it is it is wow honestly you should you might
as well own it like if you're gonna have nick because then
like at least people would like because like you can get a
refund in two hours like why why are you tricking people to
buy your game when you can get a refund in two hours like
wait they did oh like i love overwatch by the way but i'm
like any big the thing is any big multiplayer game will have
negative reviews on steam because you cannot make anyone
happy like it's it is a hundred percent if you look up any
big multiplayer game with like with like a ranked
competitive system nobody is fucking happy and somebody will
complain like like i swear people be like no you can't say
no that's not true i love blah blah blah if that game is on
steam there is 100 that the reviews would either be like
negative or mixed because people would be like okay team
fortune 2 never had a rank system it never had it never had
an actual rank system it had like fun moments funny ha ha
things to do there but it never really had a rank system and
when team fortress 2 came on steam people were a lot nicer
back then people people were when people were a lot nicer
when it came to like online reviews and also they had hats
nobody would complain about a game that has hats like
like apex i've good oh no when apex first came on steam like
those reviews were not great like i i no no no i remember
because i remember have been forced to download Apex on
Steam and it was like extremely negative the reviews because
everyone that got fucked over and rank is right there ready
to complain about it on Steam because if you give people a
chance to complain i.e.
me a platform right now because we literally spent an hour
complaining about everything
we will fucking complain complain like we will we will
complain um but yes well anyway welcome to the tomato farm
everybody thank you thank you for joining the membership i
really appreciate you guys welcome to the farm and thank you
everybody for the akasupas i really i have so many super
chats to catch up on i'm so sorry i i'm so sorry if i didn't
read you i haven't read a single super chat you know what
the next person that super chats you won the gotcha I'm
gonna read your fucking super chat right here right now give
me titan fall three I am so sorry to tell you but I feel
like at this point it's easier to get a million dollars than
it is to get to get titan fall three like it's easier to win
a lottery than the other one because like I as long as apex
still makes money like I'm sorry Also, oh, thank you for the
super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hi, too bad for the guy below him.
He did not win the gotcha.
Fastest fingers in the West.
Oh, my God.
Jenny, thank you for the akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
All right, this person also won the gotcha.
Thank you, guys.
I really appreciate it.
But yes, unless you buy EA, I apologize.
But I really don't think we're ever getting Titanfall 3.
Because Apex just makes way too much money at that point.
Like, it just, as long as it keeps making money, as long as
you keep buying those skins.
I don't know.
Because I was a fool.
I was a fool too.
I used to buy heirlooms back then.
And then, like, I realized.
Like, the heirlooms were so distracting.
I, I, I, for me, like, because I play rank a lot, I don't
like equipping heirlooms because, like, it's just so
distracting for me.
And they're so fucking big.
But, Apex, if you want to make a Doki heirloom themed, I
would equip, I would buy all your heirlooms.
I'll just give back your money.
All right, anyway.
anyway before i give you guys a name and a form i want to
show you guys the lunar new year merch that will be released
tm soon i don't know when we're gonna be putting it up on
the store but like um i really really want to show show you
guys what it is uh uh but anyway so um one of the artists
the one of the artists i reached out to like they didn't
know who i was before because they're like like uh who the
fuck is who the fuck is so cute um and then they're like
wait i used to watch your streams and they're like oh please
come to billy billy and whatever you have a chance to um and
stuff and they like gave drew like they drew like freebies
for all of us too so like i'm definitely gonna be using
because they drew like a free gift for all of us uh to use
uh for like merch and stuff afterwards because they're like
wait i love watching you um but like let me show you this is
the same artist that did uh the acrylic this is the artist
that did the acrylic stands uh let me show you it's so cute
I was like oh my god it's so cute and they did like extra
stuff for it too because I was like you don't have to but
they like added the extra like extra stand with my name on
it and everything so look at it look at the look at the they
didn't have to but they like added the extra like stand for
like the name too it's so cute but this would be the lunar
new year acrylic stand like oh my god hello hello joki here
uh but yes thank you shout out to this artist um and also
they did uh this is gonna be a pillow design like you know
there's like mini pillows and stuff so this is gonna be like
the pillow artwork and then we also have so this is a
freebie they drew which I'll definitely throw it in um and
for those who want to buy bundle so they drew these as
freebies uh so like there's like the button designs um and
also like some stickers here and everything and it's so cute
I know they drew that for free I was like oh my god thank
you I was so sweet i was like oh my god this artist is so um
so sweet and everything i thought it was incredibly cute
anyway also there's the red pocket envelope what's their
name it is let me i'm gonna butcher their name let me grab
it real quick it is uh uh i'm gonna show the um i'm gonna
show the i'm gonna But this is their Twitter.
Give me a sec.
I can't find my cursor.
But this is their Twitter for those who want to check the
artist out.
Oh my god.
It's so cute.
Also the Red Pocket Envelope.
So there's like three designs.
And I was blown away because I gave them artistic freedom
for both.
But, sorry, I can't read.
Sorry, only my manager knows how to read.
Um, but like, this is like the, uh, the red pocket
envelopes, too.
So, like, oh my gosh, the outfit is so cute!
It's so cute.
But there's like three designs.
There's this one as well.
And then there is, um, the last design is...
uh this is the last design here and like oh my god they were
so fast i really did not expect them to finish the artwork
uh like in time for the lunar new year i i really so like do
you see the gold the ones that have gold will have like gold
foil print on it so it's gonna be like the you know like the
reflective gold in the lunar new year stuff like it is gonna
have like the gold reflection to it too i think like i've
always loved i've always loved uh designing merch or like
just um like have ideas for like merch and stuff so i'm i'm
going wild with these um i guess like also this is the
artist for the red pocket envelopes and stuff so So, it's
super exciting to be able to, like, I guess, like, have all
these ideas and stuff and being able to, being able to,
like, put it out there.
And, uh, what's super exciting is that I'll, I always love
spoiling, like, my next, like, idea, but, like, the next
merch drop that I'm planning on doing after, this one won't
be, like, super soon, by the way.
just coincided with each other because, like, Lunar New Year
and, you know, like, the merch that the debut merch I had
made, like, three, four years ago.
The four-year-old merch.
That's my debut merch.
Yes, the Red Pocket Envelopes will be sold as a set.
And there'll be five envelopes per design.
So it'll be, like, five envelopes per design.
Um, and uh but yeah anyway what was i gonna say fuck guys oh
yeah sneak peek but the one thing i'm um currently working
on now um is a uh i contacted an artist to do like one
singular you know like those like um like a one singular
keycap design so it's not a keyboard set or a keycap set but
it's like one keycap um that has like uh uh where where it's
like laser engraved so that light will it'll be like my face
and then like light can shine through it past the line all
right so stuff like that um so yeah artist in keycap it'll
be one artist in keycap design that i'm working on right now
um trying to find a manufacturer also like all these stuff
all these merch uh i personally find the manufacturers and i
personally reached out to like research like manufacturers
and stuff for like samples and everything and also um i
reached out to artists that that would i think would make
these like i reach out to artists that i think will do it
justice type deal but yeah i'm doing the next merch drop
drop not anytime soon by the way will be an artist in keycap
which is something i've always wanted to get that made um
and i'm super super duper excited and everything so yeah
just something to look forward to very slowly and honestly
like doing this is also like stuff i want of myself so
you know i like i want to look at myself more so then i was
like these are things i want personally so like so i think
these are um but usually you can you have to buy like you
have to buy a minimum amount of stock so like it's a good
benefit because i can i can acquire these items um and not
have to worry about the extra stock i can because when you
get things manufactured usually it's a minimum amount that
you need to order because I remember when I was trying to
order like I was talking to manufacturers for like red
pocket envelopes they were like um yeah but you have I was
like can you like make like a hundred and they're like
minimum order a thousand
I was like oh my god thank god I have an audience now so I
can't get away with that like they're like minimum order
1000 i'm like what the fuck wow oh god that's a lot um um so
yeah i was just like oh thank fucking god at least i can
sell my extra stock that i'm not gonna keep
no it's not like i it's not about like i can afford it's
more like if i didn't you know if i fan base or if i didn't
have an audience i was like what the fuck am i gonna do with
950 of them like what am i like what am i gonna do with all
of these like what and i'm like oh thank god people will
actually buy it this time i'm like oh thank god because i'm
not like a licensed character you know it's not like i'm
fucking sonic or something sonic the hedgehog we're like I'm
gonna buy it.
I'm just me.
So I was just like, oh my god.
Like, think I'm so happy you guys love me enough to buy, buy
the extra stock.
And then I got it.
Why you need this?
So I can use it and look at my, I can use it and look at
myself because I love myself a little bit more now.
thank you for the magenta soup but thank you thank you uh
yes so many options awesome things plan tons of stuff for us
to look forward to thank you thank you thank you for the
magenta soup but thank you thank you i mean i also not just
like merch of like you know merch i get of myself like made
by me but also like i'm super excited to like work with
other like distributors you know like being like like other
companies that want to make merch of me and stuff and that
would be super exciting you know the one thing I'm gonna
tweet, actually I'm gonna tweet that out later.
I'm gonna tweet, wait, where's my, I'm gonna tweet that out,
but I'm gonna add Funko Pop and
Alright guys, my dream collab would be a Funko Pop and a
Nendroid, but like, I feel like it's more, it's easier maybe
to get a Funko Pop than it is to get a Nendroid.
Okay, hear me out hear me out why I would want to get a
Funko Pop.
You had to think of it business wise.
Just think about it business wise.
Why Funko Pop would be so funny.
But basically the thing about Funko Pop collectors is that
they will fucking buy every single Funko Pop to their
collection it doesn't matter if they don't know who that
person is they are insane collectors that will collect every
funky Funko pop out there so then they're gonna see a Doki
Funko pop and then they'll be like who the fuck is Doki bird
I must have her in my collection and then normies my OBS
just
Holy shit My OBS disconnected While I was talking about Fuck
off
Anyway Anyway as I was saying As I was saying You have to
understand Like Normies would be like Would see that at like
Fucking game stuff because who the fuck buys games at
GameStop?
Every fucking and conventions.
There's always 10 to 20 sellers selling Funko Pops and only
Funko Pops.
So a Doki Funko Pops would be everywhere.
It'll be mainstream.
It'll be a hot topic.
Imagine going to a hot topic store and seeing a doki funko
pop like you barely find anime stores because like people
just order online people don't really order online and funko
for funko pops they fucking go to hot topic or walmart i
could be in walmart i could be in fucking walmart i could be
a walmart exclusive Just like think about like the dokey
flocked version I could have like multiple versions of
myself in Funko pop And like and like it could be like the
dokey metallic Walmart exclusive Just business wise it is
the smartest thing I can ever do Like like think about it No
the dokey the original dokey Would be...
Oh my god!
Yodgy, thank you for the 50 gift dishes!
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Like, I kept different exclusives in different stores.
So, like, the Doki Metallic version will be in Spencer's.
The Doki Flocked version will be at Toys R Us only in
Canada.
Because Toys R Us is apparently bankrupt in America.
I...
The fucking...
the um the two feet tall dokey funco pop exclusive at at
target just imagine the possibility and then they can make
different outfits peep normies will have to collect me
because they need to collect all the fucking funco pops in
the world so like they are forced to look at me and then
maybe they'll look me up you know maybe it's i'm not just a
funco pop in their collection maybe it's they'll just look
me up as well and then they become fans of me and that is
why Funko Pop is my dream collaboration and also Nendoroids
because like that's obviously a better figure and the thing
is unlike Nendoroids because Nendoroids are very picky on
who they pick to make into a figure
Funko Pops.
They love making Funko Pops.
So there is a higher chance.
There is a higher chance of me being picked up by Funko Pops
than it is to be picked up by Nendoroid.
Because they love making, they love licensing things.
So that's, well, that's my TED Talk.
That is my, That is my TED talk for Funko Pop of the day.
Anyway, let me, I'm going to tweet at Funko Pop real quick,
guys.
Can you give me something?
Let me add Funko Pop real quick, guys.
Guys, this is important.
I need to add Funko Pop real quick.
All right.
Collab.
DMs are open
Alright, alright, there you go Anyway There you go, sorry, I
tweeted at Funko Pop.
I hope that maybe they'll see this and be like, who the fuck
is she?
Oh, my God.
Anyway, oh, my God.
Mika, thank you for the 50 gift of ships.
Thank you, thank you.
And you know they love to do anime stuff.
I'll be like, come on, I could be your first V-Tuber.
Wait, no, I'm not even their first V-Tuber, am I?
like Kisuna, I got a Funko Pop.
I don't even know.
They have so many Funko Pops that I don't even know if they
already made a Funko Pop for a VTuber.
There's been so many.
But if they haven't, come on, I'm right here.
I could, I could, I, come on.
I could be their first
Come on, it'll be so funny It'll be It'll be so funny
Anyway, that is why That is why Funko Pop Is my dream collab
Anyway, I was supposed to name you guys I was supposed to
posted.
Sorry.
I was... Oh, I should follow.
I'm gonna follow them, too.
You know, I should... I should follow...
Let me...
Let me follow Funko Pop real quick as well.
Oh my god, I forgot!
I need to follow Peppa Pig.
I forgot to follow Peppa Pig, my Oshi, um, on my...
On this account.
I almost forgot to follow my Oshi, Miss Peppa Pig, this
twitter account as well all right nice okay i got done with
what i wanted to um i got with what i wanted to talk about
all right anyway guys guys it is time to to name you guys
for once it is finally uh it is finally time to fucking name
you guys okay all right so someone apparently they listed
all the names suggestions shout out to natty for listing out
all the names to use to suggest um that you guys all done
it's like three fucking documents trauma right there so
suspects nesties Whatever that was Hoodlums are meme tag
Robins Nightwings Raw birds Churpsters Penu Penguins
Tomatores
Tomatores Oh my god Hello Tomatores No I can't I can't Chick
Boons Dukies Bird Rockos Chickadee Why is Tomatory Tomatory
but like not plural Like what Why is I like how they put
Tomatory twice But like one has an S on the end So you know
it's multiple people Aviators Dodokies Side chicks Boobies
Sly beaks Quack cedars potatoes, canaries, pipcheaps, little
birdies, two caneers, peck pockets, lockpeck, doko bows,
foul players, swallowbeats, wingbeats, chickpeas, crusaders,
crowsaders, hello crusaders, no, oh that's, it was almost
good, crusaders, it's just, it doesn't really, off your
tongue as good as it was as i thought uh dream birds
nightmares average chirp and joy the aces are short
clawbirds sunbirds tore you sunrisers peak beaks beacons
gale talons talonites talgales swallows again Someone really
likes to swallow Plunderbirds Skylark Bourbons McDuffin
Flock faces Halbirds Nighthawks Scuffies Treebirds Bird Bird
Scribers Oh Bird Scribers is so clever Hello Bird Scribers
But it's so fun It sounds so fucking dumb Crookies Gamefiles
Night out Nightfowl Peckling Tailors Sparrows Why do we have
sparrows but like in four different forms like In this list
Bird Brains Specters Do-chicks Victories Convicts Falons
Cartel Tori Matto Tori Matto Tori models, pancakes, dorkies,
lunatics, and mother flock.
Jesus Christ.
There's so many.
Oh my god.
All right.
So which one fucking, like, like hit that note for you guys
the most, chat?
Out of all of those names, which one was like, yeah.
yeah this is it okay I see a lot of like I see a no free
birds have been officially vetoed we are never going to be
free birds out of pure fucking spite we are never gonna be
free birds I will not have you guys be free birds that song
is fucking cursed now Oh, that's odd.
Anyway, what I was thinking of was, like, Tori Bird.
So you guys would be called Bird Bird.
Hello, my Tori Birds.
My little Bird Bird.
Okay, I see a lot of...
We're not going to be...
We are not going to be fucking Nesticles.
Alright.
No, I will never let you guys be Nesticles or Free Birds.
I see a lot of suspects.
Hello, suspects.
Welcome to the stream, suspects.
Alright, let's see.
Bird Bird is pretty cute.
I like Tori Birds.
Hello, Tori Burbs.
Or Tori Burbs with a B at the end.
So, like, Bird Burbs.
Alright, do you guys like Tori?
Okay, we're not... We're gonna have a poll.
But, like, if I put Tori Bird...
Tori Bird or Tori Burbs...
Um, in the, in the poll, would you prefer tory bird or tory
burbs or tory burbs?
Do you want to be bird burb or a bird bird?
Is either bird burb or bird bird?
Tory burbs.
Hello, my tory burbs.
Where are you doing?
Burbs.
Okay.
all right all right i have my pull then all right it's
either okay let's see i want to know what the other options
were there's like suspects and then nesties that's like
fucking nestle or some i see a lot of suspects i see a lot
of uh uh toy birds and what is the third option guys third
for the polls.
What is the third option you guys want to add in?
Tomatori.
Hello, Tomatori.
No, I'm vetoing Tomatori.
I like two syllables.
All right, guys.
I'm going to be real with you.
Two syllables.
Oh, damn it.
I feel like two syllables is like the perfect amount of
syllables when it comes to like names like doki you know and
the other one like two syllables is like the best
nesties oh my god we are not gonna be nest okay guys all
right all right i'm gonna put the poll up i mean how do i
put the poll up it's been a while okay pull all right add
option add option Okay, here you go.
Naming.
Okay, I might like start moving weirdly because I don't know
where my bindings are.
Naming ceremony.
Okay.
The first one is suspects, right?
Suspects with a K ends with a K, I think.
my god the chat is so laggy when it comes to typing there's
so many thank you everybody for watching little old me oh my
god thank you everyone um let's see okay let's see liberties
liberties look guys as much as i love to be like america i'm
not american
little robins my little robin god i'm just like batman i'm
just i'm just then it just goes into batman and robin dokey
and robin um uh okay a tory burb so you guys can be like
bird bird tory burbs tory burbs okay let's see it should be
a capital T.
All right.
We're not going to be nesticles.
I am, I have like unlimited veto power and definitely one of
my unlimited veto power is fucking nesticles.
And also free bird.
Tomatori.
Hello, Tomatori's hooter.
We're not, I am, I know I put hooters in the poll as a
fucking joke.
You guys will still, you will vote for Hooters.
And I would, I'm not going to call you guys, my little
Hooters.
Like, I'm not going to.
I am not going to call you guys, my little Hooters.
Because that has a different implication.
Funko Pop will never sponsor me if I call you guys Hooters.
Think of a Funko Pop, guys.
Think of the Funko Pop.
Um, let's see.
Eagles, night wings.
Today is such a sad day.
Just because you don't get nesticles or hooters doesn't mean
it's a sad day, guys.
There are other options here.
There are other options.
Okay, I see a lot of tomatories.
Okay, I'll put that in.
Tomatory.
And then for the surprise fourth option, I thought about it
a very long time.
And to be fair, this is a surprise option.
I thought about it for a very long time.
But I realized, wait a minute, you can't copyright the word
dragon.
Because it's a real word.
And if dragoons win, it's like crocodiles and alligators.
You know, a crocodile was still called a crocodile millions
of years ago.
It was still called a crocodile millions of years ago.
But it just evolved, you know?
It evolved.
So all I'm saying is that what I'm thinking of when it comes
to dragoons, it's like a military unit.
And honestly, you know, obviously, why did I think about
dragoons?
Oh my god, it's like StarCraft, you know?
StarCraft's my favorite game.
Anyway, obviously, it's a surprise fourth option.
It's like a surprise fourth option.
Okay.
All right, here we go.
All right, here's the pull.
Here's the pull.
Nesticles is officially out in the running.
Nesticles is officially...
Oh my god, it's so laggy in chat that it took like...
I felt like it took like an entire minute for this to load.
So...
So, here you go.
Fight.
Fight for your name.
No, Nesticles, my beloved.
Look, you guys had, like, oh my god.
Oh, my god.
You guys, like, fought so high.
For those that wanted to be Nesticles, look, guys.
Nesticles, you guys could have pretended to be Nesticles
when you guys had no.
name okay that's not my fault you had the freedom to be a
nesticle for like six days now okay you guys all had the
freedom to be a nesticle for six days those might have been
the best six days of your life but now it's time to be
renamed okay now now it's time to be renamed everyone had
six days to had six days to be whatever the they are to me
oh my god i love i love how like i could have just said
dragoons in the very beginning but i made you guys that's
typical dokey versions i made you guys fight amongst
yourselves for like six plus days deciding a new fan name
for yourself And then I'm like, JK, Dragoon's an actual
word.
Like,
I strung you along for six days yelling at each other,
trying to figure out what your new name was going to be.
But don't worry, guys.
Dragoons can evolve.
all dinosaurs eventually evolved into birds which is you
know it was like we wrote three pages of
names i like how somebody was like i was like dokey we
worked so hard coming up with all these days
We worked so hard coming up with all of these names, Doki.
I can't believe it.
All right, I'll do one more poll for you guys.
I'll do one more poll for you guys.
Because obviously, we'll have the two finalists fight each
other for, like, the true winner.
The true winner.
naming ceremony naming ceremony all right dragoons versus
suspects we just all evolved you know we just we're just
evolving the closest ancestor to the dynos if you guys
didn't know our birds is just the And we're just evolving,
everyone.
We're just evolving.
Enough years have passed by for evolution to take in its
effect.
All right, here we go.
Give us a fact that I refuse to vote.
I will only vote if it's nesticles.
Well, then, he's got to be...
Well, thank God for that.
Thank God we vetoed nesticles.
Oh, this is really...
really close though this is actually really really close
when you close your eyes does it always feel like nothing
has changed oh my god that's actually a lot closer a lot
closer than I expected I know like you guys would be like
but Doki didn't you say didn't you say you don't want to
have Goon as the as the last part because of because of what
they did to goons Dragoons would be like my only exception
to be fair Like I don't think I could ever adopt a new name
with goon in it But I just have a particular attachment to
dragoons that it will be my only exception If it wins the
poll If we win If it wins book because then it'll be
confusing that's the rule it'll be way too confusing if
there's two names i can i guess like for suspects because i
still want four different forms so like chonky peck chonky
sus oh my god how would be how do we say it would be chonky
sus or chonky
Chonky suspects.
Chonky specks.
Long specks.
Long sus.
Uh.
Egg specks.
You're the only... Yeah, but like, you know, we're gonna
have four forums.
I... There was this one design that... Like, some people
were submitting designs, and there was one design that I
would really liked that gave me some ideas.
And, like, why I was, like, thinking maybe...
we if dragoons wins um there's like this idea on how to like
this idea i wanted to do uh sus goons
sus goons i'm trying to sing like chonky peck chonky sus
long peck Sorry, long peck sounds so fucking weird Long peck
Because then I don't get to think about it as like pecks,
you know?
And then Long peck Egg peck That's a word Is it like People
are now voting for for track goods Because like, no,
actually I don't think I want to be called that I don't like
Suss goons, please, I want to be a dragoon here.
Where is...
There's no free bird!
They lost their voting power after the first stream.
Doki bros, because every time we see...
Alright.
Oh my god, okay, so like, I forgot to tell you guys this
story, But, like, when I was playing Apex, so, like,
obviously, I've been playing Apex a lot during that one
month.
But, like, one of them was...
That's so...
Okay.
Oh, wait, never mind.
I can't say it.
God, sorry.
I'm gonna, like, you're just gonna be, like, you're gonna
get blueballed for the rest of the stream because I'll never
see.
say what it was.
I guess you'll never know the story.
You'll never know something funny happened, but you'll never
know the story.
Very unfortunate.
All right, I'm gonna give you guys one more minute.
Suspects rise up if you want to defeat the old and bring in
a new generation.
dynasty you'll overthrow overthrow the old and bring in your
new dynasty suspects are you strong enough suspects to kick
those boomers out yeah suspects installed the bots new name
for the new year suspects rallied the undecided voters this
is it Rally the undecided voters.
If you want to win, you have to rally up and kick those old
boomers out of office.
They would have lost a nesticle.
You know, honestly, like 100%.
If nesticles was in there, I would 100% agree that...
That they would have one-offer dragoons.
Come on!
Suspects!
You're young?
There's more of you?
You really gotta let a bunch of old dragoons out there take
away what you believe in?
Come on!
How long are you gonna make us dance?
I just wanna see if I can get a 50-50 right now.
Come on, Dragoons.
Hold the line.
Don't let those youngins take our office.
Dragoons will be in office forever.
Suspects rally up the other ones.
Rally the nesticles to vote for you.
Oh my god, wait, suspects are actually winning.
Holy fuck.
I didn't expect that to happen.
I didn't expect that.
this move guys come on with new year new us if doki can
change their names we can too doki dragoons really you're
gonna let a bunch of like young young birds tell you what to
do come on you're a military unit you're really gonna let
birds tell you what to do fucking eat birds like
new era suspects come on dragons today we reclaim our legacy
if it's 50 50 we should pick nesticles alright nesticles is
like the third party that has like only one person in office
and even then they can't really do much it's like it's like
50 it's it's like suspects versus dragoons have like
majority of the seats and then nesticles is that one guy
like the one the one person in there that has a power there
where their boats don't really count but they're there
they're in the office push the 50 50 all right suspects i
feel like i gave you guys like so much time to like fight
for what you believe in but like just like the real world
boomers are always in charge so suspects i feel like this is
a harsh lesson of reality of what the real world is like
where even though you have a cool new idea no matter what in
the end the boomers always win because they
They'll be 90 years old and still in office and you can't do
a damn thing about it.
So like as a young one, as a little baby suspect, as a
little baby suspect, watching an anime girl show you the
harsh reality and give you a simulation of what that was
like.
in the real world.
I reject change.
Thank you for the magenta soup, Alan.
Thank you.
Like I say, Alan is one of those old goons.
He...
You have to overthrow goons like that to get what you want.
Can we be suspects on April Fool's?
Anyway, I'm sorry, I suspect.
I gave you enough time to try and overthrow the old power.
But it seems like the dragoons have evolved.
And kept...
There's birds now.
There was a 10 minute...
I gave you guys 10 minutes to fight for what you believe in.
And if you can't fucking fight for what you believe in
within 10 minutes of me giving you extra time to rally for
it, that's not on me.
That's just reality at that point.
Because in the real world, you'll have like almost a whole
year to figure this shit out.
a year but you have multiple years to try and not let the
old people win but in the end not even just in like in like
I guess like policies wise it's also like business wise too
that's why you need to overthrow any CEO that's 80 years old
I'm talking about you CEO's name I don't remember who
literally are who's literally like fucking deleting movies
for tax reasons like what the fuck okay I know I talked
about it yesterday but I have to talk about this again like
this this guy the CEO of like Warner Brothers fucking
deleted Wally Coyote for a tax break and like other studios
offered money and he's like no not enough like what the fuck
like other studios are like hey i'm willing to buy your your
movie and like no but it's basically like coyote versus acne
and it's like this like mockument i think it's like a
mockumentary style thing about uh wally coyote trying to
like uh in a court case against acne ink and like and like
apparently the test screenings was actually really nice
really did really well received um but like uh water
brothers ceo was like we need more tax breaks because we're
losing money and i'm just like what
those poor actors and those poor those poor actors and like
the the production company they leaked the production
company video of um the production company video they like
leaked the uh i guess like the cast party like the behind
the scenes of everything so you could even see like all the
set designs and everything that was built uh of all the
stuff that was built for it and it looks like so much time
and effort was built anyway anyway sorry i need to get that
out of my chest because i still can't believe they fucking
shelved that movie anyway uh happy lunar new year
congratulations you've been named it's sad that suspects
couldn't win the poll there it's sad let's say put another
poll hooners versus i like how someone was like hooners
versus We will win Nesticles Paul No Alright I'll humor you
guys I'll humor you guys I'll humor you guys Alright Alright
Just for those who are like No you don't understand
Nesticles can Nesticles will beat Dragon
Alright And it's time to give you guys a form so there was
this one artist from uh tin like her name is uh uh their
name is uh tim and uh tin they've like they've done this
concept art of your okay fuck you guys we're not gonna be
so like they they did this um concept design for for you
guys and that's what got me an idea of maybe perhaps uh we
keep we stay with dragoons also joe thank you for the 50
give the shins thank you thank you um oh shit what the fuck
okay um there was like something that came on my screen and
i thought it was showed up on stream as well like my drawing
program But then I was like, oh no, that just wasn't like on
the...
That was just covering up my YouTube preview.
So it looks like it was on screen.
So let me show you guys this picture.
So I really liked this concept.
But obviously I'm going to tweak it a little bit to make it
work more.
But I'll show you guys here.
Alright.
So now we're here.
I love how it says like subgold top donation.
sorry that was like twitch meta and all my overlays i'm
using are like old twitch stuff so so that's why it's like
what the fuck why is there that stuff so wait let me show
you guys so this is the reason why i thought about it
thought about uh because i really i liked how oops sorry i
liked how it was like um it felt like the dragoon was
evolving you know this it looked like an evolution of a drag
we're not gonna be called nesticas i was humoring you
so i is gonna i want to take like certain we're not gonna
have cheek dots too we're not we're not gonna have cheek
dots i told you we're not devolving we're evolving okay we
are we are evolving okay guys so so that's why i really
enjoyed this concept and that's what got me thinking because
into her birds so i liked how like it's like a semi
evolution of of like a dinosaur and i thought that was a
really neat concept and then the fact that it has like you
know i guess like what i say the long long goon the chunky
goon and then i don't know which one's the chunky goon not
to be fair i don't hate my little nesticles donkey don't
understand it rolls off your tongue nesticles we're not
going to be nesticles thank you for the akasupa poncho thank
you thank you I love democracy
all right all right so that's what I was thinking so like I
was thinking of like I'm trying to like think of like the
default base design because I do think like that's really
cute like the uh i like how there was somebody that was like
and i like how this is like you know remember how it was
like this the but then it went up because i don't know your
fucking head evolved fucking weirdly i guess so like instead
of the side it went up so it's it fucking went up um uh what
thank you for
Satisfiness.
What do you say?
I supered my first ever super to you a while back.
This is my first Akasupa ever.
What a perfect day to give you a red, red tangle with my...
Thank you, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
I...
This was not enough, guys.
It was not official.
I said I will humor you guys.
I don't...
did say it was out of humor and i like how you know there's
like still horns and stuff too but i don't know if like i'm
trying to figure out like the proportion wise we're like a
normal goon so i don't know if i should like you guys should
have a body or you guys just be all head like i can't tell i
i can't tell if i want you guys to be all ahead or or like
Or like have a body of...
Kazen, what would the Chonky-goon look like?
What would the Chonky-goon look like if it's like...
If you guys...
If it's all head...
Or the...
One year nest it goes...
No, Kazen!
Kazen, it'll be confusing if I change the fan name a year
after all head.
No way.
So you want to make it look like...
The thing is, I was, like, wondering how to, like,
distinguish you guys, too.
You know?
So, like, there's the tail.
Like that.
And then...
There.
It's just...
It's like a fucking tomato.
Oh, yeah.
I don't know if you guys should have wings.
I don't know.
You guys should have wings or not.
Looking pretty nesticle here.
I don't know, guys.
I don't know if you guys deserve wings.
You guys haven't.
I feel like you guys just haven't evolved into wings yet.
Like, I want to edit this a little bit, though.
Okay, so if it has wings, you guys would look like...
You guys would look like...
Like, basically like a raptor.
Like, the original concept was like that.
But I feel like it would be cuter if you just have, like...
Like, if it's just...
There's a potato arm.
It'll be... It'll look very stupid.
We need small wings.
So you want to look like this?
I don't think I want, like, the bows and stuff, though.
I was, like, thinking, like, you'll still keep number.
I've always liked that concept, but I don't think we can do
that.
I don't think we can do that.
Let us fly.
Okay, we'll let you fly.
And
then...
All right, so it'll be like, boom, boom, boom.
I don't know, I'm just like thinking like, uh...
Like, what is a way to...
What is like a way to differentiate all of you?
We obviously can't put a number anymore.
Arms and wings?
Guys, now you're demanding.
We should be flightless.
Okay, all right, we're gonna have a pull No either wings or
no wings Either Either you guys have no wings And you're
like this Or oh my god Wings Or no wings
Wings Arms or no arms The arms would be like that But then
wings I feel like arms would be better Arms would be so
funny I like how somebody was like I don't know who it was
but like please I don't want to be a bird so this is like
the next best thing we're not gonna have cheek dots I know
you guys really want I mean it does look really cute though
it does look really cute though the the bone lizard bone
oh okay wait give me a sec let me if let me check this out
real fast let me see what it looks like
let me see what it looks like without cheek dots let's see
oh no i'm trying to think right now i'm trying to think i
feel like i feel like uh give us those we deserve it
i'm trying to think i'm trying to think if you guys deserve
to have cheek dots or not bone in or bone out no cheek dots
dot cheeks will rise again
i see like no cheek dots is better just because like Just
because I think it's cuter about it.
I feel like...
I feel like it's just cuter without it, though.
Pull, please?
Okay.
Maybe...
The cheek dots for me.
I don't want to be cute.
I...
Sorry, that one guy does not want cheek dots.
He does not want to be cute, guys.
He doesn't want...
to be cute
it's like a real man doesn't have dogs it is okay okay
anyway um I want to be cute though I want to be cute fuck
that guy I think like merchant like plush was I think think
it's easier to i think it's it's better for them to not have
cheek dots because like plush wise um i personally think
plush wise no cheek dots look better um versus like i like
when you look at stuff like uh in real life because it's
hard to make cheek dots work on a plush I don't know, I
don't know, but...
No, give it back!
Alright.
Alright, and to make things easier...
Ooh, okay.
Me.
I hope it's okay if I edit the artwork a little bit just to
help me get an idea.
Alright, let's see.
And to help it...
Sinking, maybe like...
Like this.
maybe like a belly a white belly you want what white belly
or no let's see the white belly would be look like this for
the white belly like
that it's not just all yellow at that point like there's
more colors to it hat no what the fuck this is my hat find
your own hat
what the fuck find your own hat you're not gonna have hats
you're like team fortress gives you hats yeah they're
fucking go Oshi team fortress too
okay alright I have an idea alright this is a default form
right here this is going to be default guy.
And then Long Goon would be like
this is Long Goon
just like that.
Long Goon has evolved to
he's like a little how the fuck do I do like the shape?
And then Long Goon Long Goon
I'm sorry
Okay Okay The little r's The little The little r's I just
It's so good oh my god it's so good wait i love i love the
little heart oh my god all right the arms is so good let's
fix the eyes on this one i think that's why it's like been
bothering you for the longest time oh my god i'm sorry the
long the long moon's arms are so funny oh my god i can't
fucking i hate this i can't do the eyes all right that's us
all right all right and then the charm i'm thinking about
like chunky goon the chunky goon is like no legs why did the
chunky goon is just it's just no legs it's just
all right the chunky goon is just i'm trying to think how
the chunky goon would look like is it just that just like
just ahead okay okay you guys evolution didn't do you so
well the evolution didn't do you so well you don't even have
legs or arms you're just you're just ahead or maybe i could
do like
just like tiny tiny no just just that you're just ahead i
love i'm sorry longoon i love longoon the most Oh my god Oh
my god Hello Wait Wait a minute Wait okay But wait Wait a
minute Okay okay guys Okay Should this be Chonky-goon Should
this be Chonky-goon Why do we just do all head?
I can't tell.
The missing link.
I can't tell if we should have this.
Or...
Wait, what if this is the normal form?
We could have this as the normal.
I can't tell.
That's...
Make that...
Yeah, this...
What is the face?
This should...
I don't...
This is the base design.
I can't tell.
It's so good.
The stick.
The stick legs.
Or just all head.
It just goes back.
The twig legs are so good though.
Oh yeah.
I forgot the horns for each too.
No.
The longu didn't have horns.
Longu never had horns.
It was.
Only.
Uh.
It's ticklings with no heart.
We're never gonna win wars.
I can't tell.
I can't tell if I want you guys to...
I don't know if I want you guys to be all head.
Or like with the little legs.
Because it's so funny.
It's so funny.
Bro.
Buff legs to help hold up the chunk.
It's like...
I stand up.
up it's like you know like those memes or it's like oh he's
he's so fucking weak and then and he gets out it's like what
do you say what do you say like he's not gonna catch me he
has no legs and then he just stands up and is like say it to
my face they look like nesticles how would the plush work
It's like a tiny line.
It's like a tiny...
Legs are...
Okay, okay, okay.
Alright.
Chonky goons.
You have a secret power where, like, your legs are
retractable.
Okay.
What is this?
Okay, not gonna lie.
I sort of want this to be the base form now.
Wait, I can't...
I feel like this as the base form is so good.
It is so good.
good guys I feel like this should be the original for I just
think I think this should guys I'm sorry I'm sorry for this
guy but this guy is so funny okay this This is going to be
the original.
The original.
Oh my god.
Oh.
I don't even think you...
You know what?
You guys don't need horns.
I feel like no horns is fine.
You just got a tail.
I feel like...
I don't know.
Looking at it.
I think it just looks so good like this.
It's just so bring back my leg, boy.
Alright.
Here is the Longoon.
Longoon, you have real legs.
You have real legs.
And then, honestly, I like the first one.
Alright, how about we make that one the Chonkun's?
Oh, but this one is the Chonkun X-Mercet.
oh my god that's why he has legs okay chonkun's base form no
horns because you guys evolved out of the horns so this is
the base we're gonna redo all this this is this is base form
chonk long
this is the evil level one versus um and then um so you can
draw the base form with no legs if you want this can so you
can draw a base with no legs or arms so base form has no
horns he has no horns he he has evolved out of horns just
like the long one Just like the long boy.
Chonk.
The chonk one.
The chonky guy.
He's still going through evolution right now.
He's still going through evolution.
And then.
Obviously.
There's the eggs.
Eggs still exist.
The eggs still exist.
It's just you have different legs now.
And now you have weak-ass legs.
I mean, I did you all along.
Alright!
Alright, let me draw this a little better.
Let me draw this.
I just love this guy.
I love this guy so much.
Oh my god.
We're still the fresh eggs.
Oh, he's so funny.
He's just so fucking funny.
Alright, let me...
Let me do a better...
A better line art.
Okay.
Alright.
Let me...
I can't.
There's so little...
dead eyes.
Oh my god.
When he like fucking stands up and was like, what do you
say?
What do you say?
oh my god let me badden this guy up all right the death
stare i mean he can you can do different eyes you can do
this eye too so there's different eyes you can do the non
i'm gonna kill you
okay you guys have two different eyes the i'm not gonna kill
you one and then the i've seen some stuff i've seen things
so there's two sets of eyes i've seen things and i'm not
gonna i'm okay now and i'm okay but this will be default
just in case this is gonna be default
i just love the fucking Just lower the legs.
Alright, base.
The base one.
And then the giant one.
Or maybe this can have dot eyes.
No, we'll do...
Okay.
And then the giant one here.
The head empty inside.
And then here's the other one.
And then he's like...
And then
And let me Draw his chunky His chunky ass form He's like Big
He's a big boy He has the horns because he's taking a little
bit He's taking a little bit to evolve He's taking a little
bit right now sorry it's incredibly sketchy because i'm not
ready to really art today it's so it's a little bit very
it's very sketchy but i'm pretty sure somebody will be able
to draw this better than me all right but i'm giving you
guys the base design right now and then his legs his little
legs it here to um to tin for for doing for giving this
concept and making me go like whoa i really like you i
really like the concept i wonder if i should do you know and
then that's the chonky you go i feel like he should be maybe
like round okay
okay but what if what if guys He's like this big, you know?
He's...
And...
He's like...
Big...
Like, but like, what if he's like...
Huge, okay?
You need some run?
Okay.
I feel like I can...
adjust his chunkiness a little bit more give me a sec i feel
like i can adjust the chunkiness just a little bit more i
feel like it's possible i feel like you do make him like
more egg shape oh yes yes
oh yeah there you go i just needed to be i just wanted to be
wider there we go Oh, maybe it's, like, a little bit too
wide.
Let me just...
Maybe it's a little bit too wide.
There we go.
I think we can settle with the middle wide.
Because he has to be chonk.
You know?
He's chonky.
He's a wide goon.
And then...
Long goon time.
Long goon has evolved away from...
Has always...
Never had horns.
So...
He's fine.
There are...
they've always been fine so and then and poop
yep and then there you go and then finally finally egg now
you don't have spots anymore because birds don't have spots
on their on their eggs i mean some birds this this bird
doesn't maybe actually I don't know no no spots because
you're not you're not dinosaurs anymore you're an egg it's
just it's just a white egg it's just a white egg oh cracks
in the no I think if you want cracks that's your own egg
that's your own egg all right so there's the base design
obviously you can draw the base design as just a head
because you were just born like that you could either be a
headless headless version or the stick when you're just
sitting down so like when you're sitting down you guys have
no legs you know and then it's like you retract it you like
extract it
but you sit down you look like this and then when I'll be
like Alright, dragons, come over here.
You go, like, huh?
You're like, huh?
So, so, when you're like, oh my god, Doki's calling for me.
Okay, normally, normally, it's like either no legs.
And you're just like, you're just ahead.
This is standby mode.
Standby mode versus not standby mode.
Go go catch it Kune now.
Okay.
Stand by
legs.
So, um, so, like, that is the, that is the evolution line.
Energy saving mode.
Yeah, yeah.
So this is the base form.
This is regular regular mode of dragoons and then and then
this is chonky goon where you guys have not really evolved
quite so far you guys haven't really evolved so far so
you're still just a little bit a little bit behind in the
evolution line and then and then there's the long goons
where you're still lying and the tokey moins and then the
and then the iggoons are still there they're still there all
right i like this idea all right anyway anyway let's me
color this real quick so all right so the colors are gonna
be pretty easy it's gonna be we're not gonna have cheek dots
at all so it's gonna be yellow
here this is gonna be so fucking rough
i swear it looks so much better i'll do i'll like recolor
all i'll redraw this a little bit better i swear but these
are the colors i like the colors that this artist chose
because I think it's really cute.
I always like the little pastel.
I mean, I could make it a little bit lighter, maybe?
No.
Actually, I like this yellow.
And then
here's like...
I don't know if I want the little belly now.
I feel like it looks better with no belly.
Oh my god.
But yes, like previous evolution line, you don't have to be
yellow.
You guys don't have to be yellow.
You can be different colors if you really want to.
So you can be a green goon.
But like yellow is the default.
No belly or belly.
I can't tell if I want a belly or not.
I can't tell yet.
Honestly.
Keep the belly.
But maybe we can use like white instead.
Maybe.
Maybe white would look better than the pale yellow.
Oh It's true, pal.
Maybe.
I don't know if I want the belly or not.
Can't tell yet.
P-H-C.
Uh.
Maybe I put the belly like this.
Maybe it'll look better.
I can't tell.
I can't tell if I want the belly or not.
Uh.
Let's see.
Belly or no belly?
So hard to pick.
I'm so indecisive.
Yes, belly?
Belly good?
Okay, we'll keep the belly.
Alright, if you guys think belly good, we'll keep it.
Let's see.
all right and then let me give you guys the beak and stuff
beaks are always orange just so you guys know it's always
orange and then
like yeah it looks like this there you go this looks like
fucking big bird I didn't see my last he looks like fucking
Big Bird.
Oh my god.
We're in Sesame Street right now.
Alright, so this one looks like Bellia Nobell.
I guess...
There you go.
Or maybe a tiny or Bellia there you go.
This is the official designs.
The official Dragoons.
Big Bird Evolution.
Okay.
You guys can clearly draw this a lot better than what I did.
My friendly neighborhood.
Look at that.
Longoon evolved into having legs.
Congratulations.
Longoon.
You now have legs.
I mean, you had, I mean, arms, sorry.
You now have arms.
Congratulations.
Longoon.
You have arms now.
Give a warm welcome to the official Dragoon Evolution Line.
This is honestly my favorite because of the liggs
activation.
I love the liggs activation.
You can grab now.
You can grab things.
Congratulations.
Oh my god.
Congratulations, I'm so proud of all of you.
I am incredibly proud of all of you.
Anyway, so...
Egg.
We all start off as eggs.
Then we go here.
And then these guys are like awkward in between cousins.
The awkward cousins of the bun.
would it be funny though if like okay this is a little dumb
but like you would think that you would think the chunky guy
is like the biggest one but like what if they're like what
if like the chunky guys are like this size next
they're chunky but small Anyway, no, I think, like, they're
all size act.
Actually, I feel like, maybe Chonky-goon would be like this.
Because, like, you know, when you're evolving, when you're
evolving, you get...
Okay, so, like, my logic here is, like, you know, like,
dinosaurs, they evolve smaller and smaller, but, like, the
Chonky-goons, you know, because they're going into...
They're, like, birds, right?
So they're still big.
you know they're so big so we're gonna go by that logic so
next to like next to them they're like double their size you
know it's just like just like evolution their chonky goons
are bigger than the base size the base goons are small maybe
maybe so yeah there's not much going on in the chonky goons
head just so you guys know if you guys are like i'm a chonky
goon lore wise there's much not there's not a lot going on
and the horns are like sort of like poking into their brains
right now so they're still a little bit they're they're
still they're still getting there you know they're they're
getting there
so so you know just like cavemen you know like the the
cavemen they are like like base form goon is is like the
2020s right now base goons are 2020s and then chonky goon is
still 500 bc so long goon is like um the future who we
strive to be long and have in a bit thick big thick i was
thinking if the no i feel like i think like i don't know if
we should have like legs for the someone was like what about
the stick legs for eggs all right let me see the stick legs
what would stick legs look like no no wait wait actually
wait wait okay do we give the stick legs or guys do we do we
give them real legs or stick legs like do we what do you
guys want the stick legs or the or real legs okay you guys
get stick legs because you're you're from the base for
Alright, there we go.
This is the evolution line.
We've all...
We've all, like, grew as...
grew...
We all grew, guys.
All of us have evolved.
We are all birds now.
We're all birds now.
Looks scuffed, but lore, I guess.
Alright, here we go.
Here's the lore.
You have been named.
You have all been officially named and given a vision of
what you all look like.
I hope you guys are happy with your new form.
I love the little signalings me too.
It's so fucking stupid.
I love it.
You can be any color for the birds.
You can be any different types of color if you want.
Um, But yellow is the default because I'm yellow.
Yellow is the default.
But you can see any different colors.
Reject evolution.
Remain a dinosaur.
Lord Kurosus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Nesticles.
Let's go.
We're not nesticles.
We're dragoons.
I mean, if you want pants, you can have pants.
Like, I'm not going to.
like I'm not going to say no you it's your vision anyway
huge shout out to tin for the concept I might be lazy and I
might tin if you're watching this right now I might
commission you to do the rep to make a better reference
sheet of this because this is just me fucking sketching it
out and I feel like it's so dirty right now it's so it's so
rough I feel like Tim will do a better job and put much more
effort.
And I should repay you for such a neat concept.
I really did like the concept that they did.
What would happen if Long-A-Goon is just a nesticle?
Okay.
I wonder what it would be like if it just has no arms.
Oh, no.
That looks so bad.
It's like...
You need arms.
Long Goon needs arms.
This is it.
This is the evolution line.
Size-wise.
Chunky Goon is much bigger.
It's bigger than base Goons.
Default Goons.
The Chunky Goon is ginormous compared to the Default Goons.
And then Long Goons is like just long.
The body is very similar.
to the default goon um he just has a very long neck that's
really it and then there's eight goons with his fucking
stick legs hey i think we did it we named we named and gave
you guys a form oh my god this should have been on done on
like day two but like there should have been a lot of things
done i did my best all right i did my best all right I hope
you guys liked the little naming ceremony for all of you.
And also for all the naming ceremony and your true form.
Your true form.
My little dragoons.
My little dragoons that are now based off of a military
unit, by the way.
Just so you all know.
It's all based off of my love.
for Starcraft and military units.
But now you're now full birds.
Now you have evolved into little birds.
But yeah.
Anyway, that was fun.
I hope you guys had a lot of fun.
I had a fun time hanging out with all of you.
I'll be posting my schedule either tonight or tomorrow.
Monday, tomorrow there will be no stream.
No stream on Sunday.
So yeah, I'll be most likely i post the schedule tomorrow
tonight so we'll do see we'll see how it goes we'll see how
it goes hey that was i hope you guys have a great lunar new
year um i can't wait to have my my dinner with my family and
uh i want to say again to everybody uh yes happy lunar new
year everyone i hope you guys have Really fun time with your
family and friends or with me because I'm your family now
We guys have fun time celebrating with me guys I'm gonna
call it over here, but thank you everybody for joining the
membership I really appreciate it everybody for joining the
membership All the gifted ships and all the super chats
today All the akas yellows Magentas and insert other colors
all right we guys have fun time hanging out i'm gonna call
it here as always everybody stay hydrated posture check get
up and move around to get that blood flowing and if you stay
up for me head to bed because you deserve it i'll see you
guys next time everyone bye guys